investigators are creating a wide
perimeter around downtown nashville as
they gather forensic evidence for clues
about the device used in the explosion
experts say they will rely on aerial
photography
surveillance footage and even gps data
in an investigation that could take
months to complete jeff begays has that
part of the story
investigators are combing the crime
scene looking for clues
starting with the identification of that
rv a bomb
scene is rich with evidence in forensics
chris swecker spent years working bomb
scenes when he was with the fbi
they may find pieces of the car that
lead them to who owned the car who
rented the car etc
to help identify leads in nashville
federal investigators will use forensic
analysis from previous incidents
involving explosives
at this secure bureau of alcohol tobacco
firearms and explosive
site in huntsville alabama you can feel
the bomb blasts
even from 200 yards away
wow but glad i had these in my ears
atf officials tell us what is left of an
explosive device
is preserved for a reason we're going to
try to
recreate we're going to collect as much
of the evidence
left over from the bomb it doesn't all
go away and that is what is happening in
nashville
the atf and fbi will look at everything
left behind
all to track down the suspect or
suspects responsible
katherine swight is a former fbi agent
this is an opportunity
on a holiday like christmas and to in a
big city like nashville
to make a splash and get their name out
there so i think we're going to see
somebody who wants to be known in the
past extremists have targeted
christmas to carry out attacks hoping
for maximum exposure
sources tell cbs news that this year
nationwide the threat level was assessed
as
low heading into the holiday for cbs
this morning saturday jeff begaye is in
washington